The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
First, welcome everybody
and good afternoon.
So the question is about
the master equation.
We know is that the
most general master
equation has to have
the Lindblad form.
And the Lindblad form
has a jump operator
which is providing dissipation.
In its simplest
case, a jump operator
is just the sigma minus operator
for spontaneous emission, which
takes us from the excited
state to the current state.
And when we have the Linblad
form, the jump operator
and it's commission conjugate,
like sigma plus, sigma minus,
appear on the right-hand
side of the master equation
with the statistical operator
here, here, and in the middle.
There are plus-minus
signs in factors of two.
So I don't have a
intuitive explanation
where the factors come from.
They come from the derivation.
But you have a question
about it, Nancy?
AUDIENCE: So after
writing the Linblad form,
we get gamma [INAUDIBLE], which
we are saying for the r dot
vector, we were
writing [INAUDIBLE].
And we said that
they are directly
coming from the first one?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So let's go right here.
That's actually what we
were going to discuss today.
We want to discuss, today,
solutions of the optical Bloch
equations.
And just to remind you, we
derived a master equation
for the density matrix.
And this master equation,
through the interaction
with the reservoir,
is acting a term
to the Hamiltonian evolution.
And this is showing right here.
These are the interactions
with the reservoir.
And in the case of the
optical Bloch equation
and spontaneous
emission, we have
only one Lindblad
operator, which
is Lindblad operator,
sigma minus,
for spontaneous emission.
So this here is
the master equation
for the two-level system
interacting with a vacuum
through spontaneous emission.
And by substituting the
two-level density matrix,
has three non-trivial
components-- sure, it's a 2
by 2 matrix, but the
craziest one-- and so
we can transform from the matrix
elements of the density matrix
to three other coefficient,
which come in very handy,
because they allow a simple
geometric interpretation.
And this is the Bloch vector.
And so the master equation,
which is shown here,
turns into a differential
equation for the Bloch vector.
And those two equations
are identical,
we've just done
those substitution.
But your question is now about--
AUDIENCE: Plus gamma, because
we have negative gamma over 2,
which is from the
first and last term.
But the gamma term should
be positive, right?
PROFESSOR: This one here?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Because that's negative gamma
over 2 times negative 2.
PROFESSOR: No.
I mean, first of all, this
is a differential equation
for r dot.
OK.
This is a differential
equation for the Bloch vector.
And we have here three
different relaxation rates,
which are gamma, gamma
over 2, and gamma over 2.
And they are all
negative, because they
are relaxation rates.
This here is not
a perfecter of r.
It is sort of a constant.
And it means, in the
long time limit-- I mean,
what happens if you have a
system which spontaneously
decay after a while?
The r vector is not 0.
The r vector is hanging down.
The system is in
its ground state.
And this is exactly that.
Wait.
Am I r dot?
Yes.
The effect is the system,
the differential equation,
has to relax towards
the equilibrium.
You can actually
re-write this equation,
r dot equals a matrix times
r minus r equilibrium.
So here is the matrix of
the optical Bloch equation.
So if you re-write that that
r dot is the matrix times r
minus r equilibrium,
then r equilibrium times
the matrix gives
something constant.
And this is exactly this here.
But it's a
mathematical identity.
Just look at it.
There is no assumption.
It's an exact re-writing
of the equation.
So it is this
equation which will
be in the focus of our
attention not only today,
but also when we talk
about light forces.
The first thing we
did is we wanted
to discuss the Mollow triplet.
And just as a reminder,
we have talked about,
at the beginning
of last class, we
talked about the fluorescence.
An atom is excited by
mono-chromatic laser light.
And at low intensity,
a delta function
emits exactly the same
frequency of light
which is provided
by the laser light.
So the incoming and
outgoing photons
have exactly the same frequency.
And this is simply a consequence
of energy conservation.
But at higher intensity,
we have sidebands.
And we understand
intuitively that we
have sidebands because the
system is Rabi oscillation.
So same, classically,
we have an emitter
which has some modulation
that creates sidebands.
But is rather easy
to understand is,
by diagonalizing
the 2 by 2 matrix,
we find that we have a splitting
of excited state with n photons
and grounds it with
n plus 1 photons.
So we have sort of a
plus and minus state.
And if we look at the
possible transitions,
we immediately find
the explanation
for the Mollow triplet.
There are three
different frequencies
which can be emitted
in transitions
between rest states.
What is much more subtle,
what cannot be obtained from
a preterbative
treatment, is the width,
how wide are those peaks
in the Mollow triplet.
And there is tens
and tens of pages
in atom photo interaction.
But at least, for
two limiting cases,
I could show you what the width
of the peak is by first saying,
if you have delta
equals 0 and g equals
0, the matrix, which
determines the dynamics,
has three eigenvalues,
gamma over 2, gamma over 2,
and gamma.
And now, if we detune, we
add a rotation along z.
If you drive the system strong,
it corresponds to rotation
around x.
You probably
remember, from 8.421
the spin in a magnetic field.
It rotates.
In a frame, rotating
with omega, it
rotates at the detuning delta.
But if you drive it, we make
it flip along the x-axis.
So we find exactly that here.
And then, it's an intuitive way
to sort of matrix, if you want,
solve the matrix mathematically.
But intuitively, what happens
is, if you have a z-rotation,
we don't change in
this eigenvalue.
And the rotation is just
aiding i omega-- omega
is the rotation-- to x and
y, because x and y are now
rotating.
So therefore, we obtained
that, in the case of detuning
the z-rotation, we have minus
gamma, minus gamma over 2,
minus gamma over 2.
And here, what appears here
is the rotation frequency.
And then, if you rotate around
the x-axis, then, of course,
nothing happens, but what
used to be the x-axis.
So we get one eigenvalue
with minus gamma over 2.
But the y and z
eigenvector are rotated.
And hand-wavingly,
I can tell you.
But you can show
it mathematically
that this means the two
new eigenvectors have
the average of those
two damping terms.
And this is 3/4 gamma.
So at least, for the two
cases for large detuning
and strong drive, I was, with
a little bit of intuition,
showing you and
deriving for you where
the non-trivial bits of the
Mollow triplet comes from.
So I hope you're,
at least, impressed
that these optical Bloch
equations are powerful
and allow us to make
predictions which
would be difficult
to obtain otherwise.
Any questions about that?
About the Bloch vector,
the differential equation,
and the spectrum of
the immediate light?
OK, we want to now discuss one
other aspect, which is actually
fairly simple.
We want to discuss
steady state solution.
For the steady state solution,
we just go to the differential
equation and say, the
left-hand side is 0.
That immediately gives us a
solution for the Bloch vector.
It gives us a Lorentzian.
But for strong drive,
it has a term here,
which we will
immediately realize
that this gives us
power broadening.
And then the steady state
Bloch vector is g delta,
g gamma over 2, delta square
plus gamma square over 4.
So we can now use this
solution for steady state
and discuss everything we want
what happens in steady state.
So one question is, if
you have an atom laser
beam in steady state, how
much light is absorbed?
Well, the basic equation is,
if you have a charged q which
moves in an electric field,
that means work is done.
So therefore, the absorbed
power is related to that.
And we can now combine q dr/dt.
And this is nothing
else than the derivative
of the dipole moment.
And then we calculate
the average.
So with that, we find the
result they the absorbed
power is given by--
just one second-- e0?
Yeah.
We express now e0 by
the Rabi frequency.
And h bar appears in omega.
But the important thing is that
we need now the dipole moment
or the derivative of
the dipole moment.
And the dipole moment is
given by the coherences
of the density matrix.
And that is, if you look
at the substitution,
is the x and y component of
the optical Bloch vector.
But now what we
need, of course, we
need only the component of
the dipole moment, which
gives a non-vanishing
term with cosine omega t.
That means, what we
need is-- I mean,
that's like an
harmonic oscillator.
The component of
the motion which
is responsible for
absorption is the one
which is in quadrature, which is
assigned only the d-component.
And that, you have to go
back and look by inspection.
But this is exactly what the
y-component of the Bloch vector
does for us.
It will become important
later on for optical forces.
So we have the
optical Bloch vector.
We are in the rotating frame.
And the one component,
which is the x-component,
is in phase with the light.
And the y-phase is 90 degree
out of phases in quadrature.
And for absorption it's, of
course, the in quadrature
component which is
relevant and which
determines light scattering.
OK, this is the absorbed light.
And we don't measure
power in watt,
we measure power in the
number of absorbed photons.
This is the natural unit here.
And for that, we have to divide
the expression by h bar omega.
And that means now that the
number of photons absorbed
per unit time is
given by the Rabi
frequency and the y-component
of the Bloch vector.
Well, we can ask
another question
and ask, what is the
number of emitted photons?
Well, the number
of emitted photons
is related to the population
in the excited state.
We take the population
in the excited state
and multiply with gamma.
This is spontaneous emission
out of the excited state.
Now, the excited state can be--
the excited state population,
you have to look up
at the substitution,
but is related to
the z-component
of the optical Bloch vector.
To remind you, the
z-component is the difference
of population between
excited and ground state.
But the sum of the two is one.
So therefore, this is now
the excited state population.
And here is our
steady state solution.
Here is our steady state
solution for the z-component.
And by using that
now, we find that we
have the result with the
Lorentzian denominator.
And what we have here is
gamma g square over 4.
And now, of course,
if you compare
that with the
solution for our y,
for the number of absorbed
photons, you find-- well,
it shouldn't come
as a big surprise--
that the number of absorbed
photon in steady state
is equal to the number
of emitted photon.
So this is one case, one
important part of the solution.
And I should have shown
that to you earlier.
When we look at the
two components, the x
and y-component,
the y-component is
absorbed, if it is Lorentzian.
Whereas, the x-component
is dispersive.
Just by inspection if these two
expressions, here is a delta.
And the delta makes the
x-component anti-symmetric.
And the y-component is symmetric
with respect to the origin.
So what we see here is
we have a Lorentzian.
The Lorentzian has a natural
line broadening by gamma.
So the full width
at half maximum
is gamma, but only in
the limit of 0 drive.
When we drive it, we have
an additional broadening,
which is called
power broadening.
So for absorption, the
full width at half maximum
is 2 times gamma square
over 4 plus g square over 2.
And this last term goes by
the name power broadening
or saturation broadening.
Just to avoid common confusion,
if you go to very high power,
that least term
doesn't play a role.
How does the line width scale
with power in power broadening?
Linear in power?
Quadratic in power?
Square root of power?
AUDIENCE: Square root?
PROFESSOR: Square root of power.
Yeah.
So in that sense,
yes, power broadening
only goes to the
square root of power.
It's, in essence,
the Rabi frequency.
If you drive the system
at the Rabi frequency,
it gets power broadened
by the Rabi frequency.
And I think that's a pre-factor
which is 2 or square root 2.
But in essence, power broadening
scales with the Rabi frequency.
So let us quickly
discuss the case
when we go to very high power,
very high Rabi frequency.
At that moment, you can just see
it in the solution on the page
above.
The z-component of the optical
Bloch vector becomes 0.
That means there is no
population difference
between excited and
ground state anymore.
We often describe the
limit of high power
by introducing a
saturation parameter, which
is defined here.
Saturation is discussed
in more details in Part 1
of the course.
But I want to relate
it here to the solution
with the optical Bloch vector.
The z-component, which
is the difference
between ground and
excited state population,
now has a very simple
form, 1 over 1 plus s.
The population to be in
the excited state is 1/2.
That's what we get
at infinite power.
And then, if the
power is finite,
it is multiplied by
s times s plus 1.
In the power broadened line
width is the natural line
width, which gives
the line width
in the limit of
low power, and then
you multiply with the
square root 1 plus s.
So what does it mean to have
a saturation parameter of 1?
Well, if you just look
how it was defined,
if you have the ground and the
excited state at a saturation
parameter of-- first, at
a saturation of infinite,
you have 50-50 population.
And at a saturation parameter
of 1, you are 1/2 way to 50-50.
That means you have
3/4 population here
and 1/4 population there.
So at this case, the number of
photons emitted per unit time,
which is always given
by this formula,
becomes now gamma over 4.
So at a saturation
parameter of 1,
the emission rate
is gamma over 4.
At a saturation
parameter of infinity,
the spontaneous emission
rate is gamma over 2.
Any questions about
steady state solution?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So what
we derived right now
is a spontaneous emission rate.
Does the optical Bloch
equation say anything
about the stimulated emission?
Or is that the fact that it
just doesn't have [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Stimulated emission
is built in the optical Bloch
equations for negligible damping
contained Rabi oscillation.
And Rabi oscillation is
the stimulated emission.
So this is being built in.
However, it seems to be
a describing the drive
field by a classical
field by a Rabi frequency.
We are not really
accounting for the number
of photons exchanged with that.
So in a way, the
driving field is always
treated in the
undepleted approximation.
It's a C number.
But in the drive through
system, but of course,
you can immediately lead
from the Rabi oscillation
the exchange of excitations
between the atomic system
and the drive field.
So yes, the optical Bloch
equations contains that,
but not in the photon picture.
AUDIENCE: If you have
Rabi oscillations,
you can kind of guess
that, every time you
go down you
simulated the events.
In space, say, you don't
have Rabi oscillations.
Can you still somehow
extract the rate?
PROFESSOR: I hope the question
we answer will become crystal
when we discuss quantum
Monte Carlo simulations.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: In quantum
Monte Carlo simulation,
we have an ensemble of atom.
And the atoms all do
Rabi oscillations.
But in steady state,
they do it out of phase.
So you have atoms
in your ensemble
which, at a given time, absorb.
And others emit in
a stimulated way.
And the effect cancels
out in steady state.
Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you're
saying, in steady state,
they kind of de-cohere.
And you don't have any net
change in those populations.
Do you still get
the triplet lines
if you don't have a modulation
of your intensity beam?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Absolutely.
The Mollow triplet is a
feature in steady state.
And maybe let me explain
that, because it's
an interesting discussion.
What will happen is, in
steady state in your ensemble,
you don't have
Rabi oscillations.
But if you would
look at one atom,
you see Rabi oscillations.
It's just when you average over
all atoms in your ensemble,
the phase of the Rabi
oscillation has averaged out.
So in other words, for
instance, what would happen
is the following.
If you take a steady
state solution
and you ask, what is the dipole
moment as a function of time
in steady state, you
will find that this is 0.
So you would then
ask, hey, where
is the light emitted, because
isn't the light emitted
by a time-dependent
dipole moment?
What you really
have to do is, when
you want to study light
emission in steady state,
you can't look at
expectation values
because they're not changing
as a function of time.
What you have to do is you
have to look at the correlation
function.
And the correlation
function sort of
tells you-- let me just use
it for Rabi oscillation.
If one atom is in the excited
state, a Rabi period later,
it would be again in
the excited state.
So although you are
in steady state,
you have correlations because,
if you look at your ensemble
and see there is a fluctuation
where the atom is excited,
you will actually find
a co-related fluctuation
a Rabi period later.
So in steady state, when
you want to study dynamics
like the Mollow
triplet, you should not
look at the solution
for the dipole.
You should look for the
solution of the correlation
of the correlation function.
And I made this cryptic
remark on Wednesday
that this correlation function
follows the same differential
equation as the
expectation value.
Therefore, when I try to
discuss for you the line
width of the Mollow
triplet, I simply
use the matrix for
the Bloch vector
knowing that it is the same
matrix, the same differential
equation which will describe
this correlation function.
But it is important here
that, in steady state,
the average values are 0,
but we have fluctuations.
And it is the
fluctuations which emit
the light, the fluctuations
which emit the Mollow triplet.
And fluctuations are described
by quantities like this.
So it's a little bit beyond what
I want to discuss in the book,
but atom photon indirection has
a wonderful chapter on that.
Other questions?
There is another important case
of the optical Bloch equation,
which is the weak excitation
limit, which is simple.
But I've already asked you to
look at it in your homework
assignment.
OK, let's now come to the
third aspect of master equation
solutions of optical
Bloch or master equation.
And these are damped
vacuum Rabi oscillations.
Yes.
I really like this
example in this chapter,
so I hope-- well, I think
we have many highlights,
but this is a
really nice example.
I learned it from
Professor [? Schwan ?]
when he introduced it.
And what I like
about it is I can
use it to show you what
other Lindblad operators may
be important.
So you suddenly understand,
in a bigger context,
what the master equation is.
And then we continue
with an atomic cavity.
And the damping is no longer
by spontaneous emission.
The damping is by photons
sneaking out of the cavity.
So we really learn
something which
is similar to optical
Bloch equation,
but in another context.
And often, if you see two
different realizations
of similar physics,
you maybe realize more
what is more generic and
what is special for instance
of spontaneous emission,
so I really like that.
But also, I found
that this example
allows me to introduce to you
the concept of the quantum Zeno
effect and the concept
of atypical elimination
of coherences.
So it's a wonderful
example which connects us
with a number of
really neat concepts.
So with that promise,
let me remind you
that, in the master
equation, when we derived it,
we got an exact expression
when we did second order
perturbation theory.
And the structure which came
was this double commutator
between the interaction operator
and the steady state operator.
Just to remind you, in the
interaction picture-- first
in the non-interacting,
in the normal picture,
the derivative of the density
matrix is a commutator with h.
In the interaction
picture, it's a commutator
with v with the interaction.
But when we iterate an
equation to second order,
we plot the first result
into the equation.
Then we get, in second
order, this structure.
And if I, by expanding
the commutator,
we obtain the
following structure.
And that gave rise
to the Lindblad form
of the master equation, which
is rho dot equals a Hamiltonian
part.
But then we have now a
sum, v, the interaction
with the environment,
can be a sum of mu
dot b and b-- and so
an external b field
times magnetization and dipole
moment times an electric field.
It can have a number of terms.
And therefore, in general, we
have more than one Lindblad
operator.
But the structure
is always given
by this commutator in
the following form.
OK.
So we have this
general derivation.
But until now, we
have only looked
at a system which
is a simple atom.
And the environment
was the vacuum.
So this is our environment.
And also, the environment was
always in the vacuum state.
So these were our assumptions.
And that means that the
only Lindblad operator,
the only jump
operator in this sum
is sigma minus for
spontaneous emission.
And by inserting
this jump operator
into the Lindblad form
of the master equation,
we find the optical
Bloch equation.
But now let's do cavity QED.
And there are lots
of experiments
going on in the research
group of Professor Vuletic.
And in this situation,
our system is actually not
just the atoms, it's the
atoms and a single mode
of the cavity.
This is our system.
And the environment
are all other modes.
So in other words,
the atoms interacting
with a single mode of the
cavity, this is our system.
And the environment
is now accessed
by emitting-- the
atom is emitting.
Or there are photons
leaking out of the cavity,
because the cavity mirrors do
not have 100.0% reflectivity.
I will immediately reduce
it to one Lindblad operator.
But we could now say that this
system, in its full glory,
has four different
Lindblad operators which
provide dissipation,
which provide coupling
to the environment.
The first one is simply
what we had before,
spontaneous emission.
However, if we allow that
the environment is thermal,
we have to multiply.
Well, whenever you have
emission and you have already
population in a
mode, and thermal
is a number of thermal photons
in every mode, on average,
then you have an extra bosonic
or photonic stimulation term.
That's stimulated emission,
but not by the laser beam.
It's now stimulated emission
by a thermal occupation
of all the other modes.
So just assume,
for that purpose,
that you have a cavity here.
But the cavity is now
in a black body cavity.
And everything, all
modes in the vacuum,
are no longer vacuum modes.
They are occupied
within thermal photons.
Of course, if this
is the case, we
have also the opposite effect.
You can see by
unitality, namely,
that we can have--
oops, n should be--
but that we have an
absorption process.
We absorb a photon from
the thermal background.
But now, we have
two more processes.
And this is photons
leaking out of the cavity.
When a photon leaks out of
the cavity, this leakage
is not coupled to the atom,
it's coupled to the mode.
We describe the mode
by a mode operator, a.
So now, the leakage
out with the rate,
kappa, is presented by that.
But in the case of
thermal photons,
we have stimulation by
the thermal photons.
And also, if we have
thermal photons,
photons cannot only
leak out of the cavity,
they can also leak
into the cavity.
So we have assumed here that
we have n thermal photons
in each mode of the environment.
So in other words, if you
want to look at, for instance,
Serge Haroche does experiment
in the wonderful experiments
in the microwave domain.
He has cavities at, I think,
gigahertz frequencies.
And even at cryogenic
temperature,
there are occasional thermal
photons in this mode.
But you are now
expert enough that you
would know how to
set up a master
equation for that situation.
But I want to discuss
simple limiting cases.
So I think you are
glad to hear that we
are choosing 0 thermal photons.
So therefore, we assume we
have a cavity in vacuum.
And therefore, we only need the
Lindblad operators, L1 and L2.
And we want to describe the
system which has only one
x, which has, maximally,
one excitation.
We try to keep the
density matrix small,
so we only want to
consider three states.
So when I said there
is one excitation,
it is, of course,
the state which
has no photon in
the excited state.
The state two is we have the
ground state and one photon.
And those two states are
coupled by the cavity.
And since I really want to
discuss the simplest case which
already illustrates all
the concepts I want to do
is they are coupled by the
vacuum Rabi oscillation.
And we have discussed
vacuum Rabi oscillation
in part one of the course.
But it's very simple.
It's just two levels coupled.
It's a 2 by 2 matrix,
so this is something
you are familiar with.
But now, the master equation,
the Lindblad operator
bring in the third
level, which is
the ground state
without photons.
And this can happen in two ways.
One is spontaneous emission.
The excited state emits,
but not into the cavity.
It emits to the side.
So spontaneous
emission can take us
down here, or when the
excitation is in the cavity.
We have one photon
in the cavity,
this photon can leak out.
And the rate that is kappa.
And since we have talked
about spontaneous emission
so much with the
optical Bloch equation,
we want to discuss now the case
where gamma can be neglected.
And we want to
understand what happens
when the only
dissipation of the system
comes by photons leaking
out of the cavity.
Any questions about the
system and the motivation?
So our system is now
an atom with a cavity.
The environment is a vacuum.
But the process of
dissipation relaxation
is no longer
spontaneous emission,
it is the photon leaking
out of the cavity.
And this realizes
different physics.
And I hope, by experiencing
these different physics,
you have sort of a nicer
picture what is dissipation
in an open system
and what is similar,
but what is also different
or spontaneous emission.
[? Koren? ?]
AUDIENCE: If you're considering
only kappa, isn't there
an equivalent process of
order kappa that takes you
to ground of two
photons in the cavity?
Don't you have to consider
that state as well?
That term would be of
order kappa as well.
PROFESSOR: So great.
The question is I
restrict the Hilbert
space to maximally
one excitation.
So this is how we start out
with our differential equation.
AUDIENCE: Oh, this
isn't in a thermal bath?
I thought we were
assuming we had a--
PROFESSOR: Oh, sorry.
I first made
everything complicated.
But then I said, now,
let's make it simple.
We assumed the
thermal bath is 0.
So we reduced--
In a way, yes, I told you here
are four Lindblad operators,
and you can describe
everything you want.
But then I said, hey,
two of them become 0,
because we eliminate
the thermal bath.
And now I make the approximation
that spontaneous emission
is negligible.
And now we are back
to the situation
which is nice for
classroom discussion.
We've only one
term left, and this
is the leaking of the
photon out of the cavity.
So I will show to
you what happens.
But ultimately, when we make
the cavity better and better
and kappa smaller and smaller,
I will say, wait a moment.
We now have to check that
our solution is still
consistent with our assumption
that spontaneous emission can
be neglected.
So that's sort of
what you want to do.
Yes.
Let's just get two more pages.
OK.
So what we want to
do is we want to look
for the dynamics of the system.
We start out in state one.
So we inject one excited
atom into the cavity.
And what we want
to learn now is--
and it has a lot of
interesting physics in it--
what will happen as a function
of this new dissipation, kappa.
Well, qualitatively, it
should be pretty clear.
If kappa is 0, we have
vacuum Rabi oscillation
between state one and state two.
If you then put a little
bit kappa into the system,
you have a Rabi oscillation,
but they are getting damped.
And like in any oscillator,
if you crank up the damping,
you go into an
overdamped regime.
And this is exactly what
the equations give us,
Rabi oscillation, damped
Rabi oscillation, and then
overdamped regime.
And actually, the most
interesting regime for us
will be the overdamped regime.
That's something we
haven't encountered.
But let me just, before
we go there, write down
the master equation for you.
So without the photon
leaking out of the cavity,
we have the following terms.
Without the photon leaking
out of the cavity, of course,
state three is not involved.
We simply have Rabi oscillation
between state one and state
two.
And this is actually also like
the optical Bloch equation.
Without damping, it's simply
the Jaynes-Cummings model.
Minus, that's this.
And for the coherences,
we get omega 0
rho 1, 1 minus rho 2, 2.
But now, we put in
the terms with kappa.
The state, which is
the state two, which
is the ground state
with the photon,
has now a damping term, because
the photon can leak out.
We get, of course, an
equation for the ground
state, the population,
the photon leaks out.
And we populate state three.
And the damping also
affects the coherences.
And the form of the master
equation, the Lindblad form,
gives us the following
damping term.
So there are two
new concepts which
I promised you to introduce.
One is the idiopathic
elimination of coherences.
And the second one is
the quantum Zeno effect.
So first of all, if you look
at the differential equation,
and when kappa is small,
in particular, kappa
is smaller than 2 times
the vacuum Rabi frequency,
then the population to be in the
excited state, which is rho 2,
2, undergoes Rabi oscillation.
And those Rabi oscillations,
this population
is damped by e to
the minus kappa t.
So what I want to discuss
now is the overdamped case.
And actually, before
I derive it for you,
I wanted to ask you
some clicker question.
I'm afraid I put the books
out, but somebody put it away.
So nobody took clickers?
So why don't we just
pass them around?
And I can already
formulate the question.
I think you know by now
that I have a preference
to maybe ask you questions about
really simple quantum physics.
Quantum physics is sadly
enough that nobody fully
understands it.
And we want to improve on that.
So I want to test your intuition
by looking at the situation.
We have an excited
state without photon.
We have a ground state.
So I want to test your
intuition in the following way.
We have Rabi oscillations
between two levels.
The case in the cavity is, it is
Rabi oscillation between state
two and state one,
but it doesn't matter.
You can also assume that
it is Rabi oscillation
between hyperfine levels.
And the Rabi oscillation
is driven by an RF field.
And the one thing
we introduce now
is we introduce damping
kappa to this level.
But we start out
the system with all
of the population in this state.
And in the overdamped case, when
kappa is sufficiently strong,
then we know an oscillator
will be overdamped
and will no longer oscillate.
And in this situation,
the probability
to be in the initial
state will decay.
e to the minus kap-- e to the
minus-- how should we call it?
gamma t.
So it decays with
the decay rate kappa.
And my question for you is,
A, B and C, whether the decay
rate, kappa, is proportional
to the damping rate, gamma?
Proportional to the
inverse of gamma?
Or independent of gamma?
So we've exacted this system.
The system has possibility
of Rabi oscillation.
I showed you the
damped Rabi oscillation
and in the limit of small kappa.
But now you go to the
overdamped regime.
And my question is, if
the system is overdamped,
will this decay rate
increase with kappa?
Decrease with kappa?
Or will it be independent
of a damped regime?
All right.
OK.
There's a clear neutrality.
Let me not yet
discuss the answer.
Let me maybe try to give
you another problem.
And you should maybe figure
out if those two problems
are related.
I want to ask you now
something simpler.
There are not three
levels involved,
there are two levels involved.
But one of the level
is broadened by kappa.
Call it an unstable state.
Because it can decay with
the rate, kappa, and we
often show something
which is broadened.
And now we have a matrix element
between the discrete level
and the broadened state,
which I call omega.
It's a matrix element
or Rabi frequency.
And now you should
figure out what
is the physical
picture which describes
the coupling of a discrete
initial state to something
which is broadened.
It's now the transition rate
from the original state.
Does the original state decay
with a collectivistic rate,
which is omega?
Or is it omega
squared over kappa?
Or is it none of the above?
So coupling between two
levels, very, very simple.
But one level is broadened.
OK.
Yes, it's Fermi's Golden
Rule, what I'm asking you.
This is nothing else
than Fermi's Golden Rule.
We couple from one level into
some continuum of states.
If I take one state and
smear it out over a width,
kappa, the density of states,
the density of modes which
appears in Fermi's Golden
Rule, is 1 over kappa.
And Fermi's Golden Rule
tells us that the coupling
is the matrix element squared
times the density of states,
which is 1 over kappa.
So this is nothing else
than Fermi's Golden Rule.
OK.
Why don't we come back
to the first question
now where we have two
discrete levels, maybe
two hyperfine states, which are
coupled by a Rabi frequency?
But then one of the
hyperfine states
decays because there is
some leakage, or we--
I don't know-- we interrogate
this state with laser
beams or such.
We make it unstable.
We allow this state to
decay to another state.
And the question is, if we
make the decay of that level
stronger and stronger, does
the decay of the initial state
increase?
Decrease?
Or is of that?
Good.
So what you have learned here
is that, actually, the more we
damp the system on this
side, the longer-lived
is the initial state.
But it's trivial.
It's just Fermi's Golden Rule.
When you couple into a
level which is broadened,
the coupling becomes weaker and
weaker because, well, that's
what Fermi's Golden
Rule tells us.
I want to now derive this
situation for you for our atom
in the cavity.
And I will say that this is one
example for the quantum Zeno
effect.
But let me already
explain to you
what the quantum Zeno effect is.
Zeno is a Greek philosopher.
And the Greek philosophers
had some deep thoughts
about the nature of time,
the nature of motion.
And I think, in the
Greek philosophy-- sorry.
I didn't go-- I mean, I don't
have a strong background
in philosophy, but
I think the idea
is that motion is when
something moves around.
But it takes some time to move.
So if you observe
it, it can't move,
because every time you observe
it, you localize something.
That's the idea.
If you see an arrow, the moment
you observe it, it's localized.
And if you localize something
to often, it cannot move.
And this is sort of
what you can say here.
The system wants to
evolve to a second state.
But kappa can actually
be a measurement process.
We can just shine a
strong laser on this state
and figure out has
something arrived here.
And the more often we look, the
stronger our measurement is,
the less the system can evolve.
So a measurement of what
arrives in this state
slows down the
dynamics to that state.
And this is called the
quantum Zeno effect.
It also goes by the name
of quantum Zeno paradox.
But it's just quantum
mechanics, it's not a paradox.
In the popular world, it
is sometimes paraphrased
as if you observe the tea
kettle, the water never boils.
But you see now
where it comes from.
OK, so this is the
quantum Zeno effect.
And we want to now, by
looking at the master
equation for an
atom in a cavity,
I want to show you the
limit that it really
comes out of the
master equation.
Questions about that?
OK, so this is the
quantum Zeno effect.
And well, one of the nicest
papers on the quantum Zeno
effect-- well, I'm biased here--
but it was written by my group,
because we used the
Bose-Einstein condensate.
We had an RF coupling to
another hyperfine state.
And then we used a laser beam
and observed the population
in the final state.
And we saw that the
effect of the RF drive
became weaker and
weaker and weaker,
the stronger we made the
measurement in the final state.
And this is the reference.
And our work was the first
quantitative comparison.
You can now do a
measurement by just
using a strong laser in,
maybe, every millisecond or so.
Or you can use a weaker
laser beam continuously.
So we showed in this work
that the quantum Zeno effect
is the same, whether you do
a pulsed observation, which
is a strong measurement, or
continuous weak measurement.
OK.
But let's now, after
this short interlude,
go back to the master equation.
So our job is now to
solve this master equation
for the limit of strong damping.
And what we will
find, actually, is
we will find both the quantum
Zeno effect and another tidbit.
We will also find
the Purcell effect,
which is enhanced spontaneous
emission to a cavity.
Now the way how we solve
this master equation
in this limiting
case is by the method
of idiopathic elimination
of coherences.
And let me explain it to
you with that equation.
What we have here is the
derivative of the coherences.
And when you look at
the right-hand side,
the derivative of the coherences
is kappa, a damping terms,
times the coherence.
Well, if you have
an equation which
says a dot equals minus
strong damping times a,
you have a very rapid
exponential damping.
The system immediately
gets into an equilibrium.
And the equilibrium is
given by the first term.
So if you have a situation that
the population do not rapidly
change, then this
equation can be
written that we have
a very rapid damping.
And ultimately, the
coherences settle
to an quasi-equilibrium
value in a time 1
over kappa, which is
given by the first term.
In other words, you
set the time derivative
of the left-hand side, 0.
And then the coherences
are expressed
in terms of the slowly
changing quantity, which
are the populations.
So let me repeat.
If coherences are
rapidly damped,
we can neglect the
time derivative
of the left-hand side.
And at any given
moment, the coherences
will be given by an expression
which involves the population.
And if the populations
slowly change,
the coherences
will slowly change.
Or in other words,
the coherences
follow the population.
And the lag time is,
at most, 1 over kappa.
And we are in the
limit of strong kappa.
This principle of
eliminating coherences and we
simply get a master
equation for population
is called the idiopathic
elimination of coherences.
It's also called by Eric
Hargan in his famous work
about synergy by the principle
that, if you have rapidly
damped modes, they are
slaved by the slow modes.
In other words, the rapidly
damped degrees of freedom
follow the slow
degrees of freedom.
And this is what I just said,
that the instantaneous value
of the coherences is always
given by the population.
So let me just write that down
and see where it takes us.
So we have the
situation that we want
to now look at the
case of strong damping.
This is the overdamped case.
And we use now the method
of idiopathic elimination
of coherences, because
they are rapidly damped.
And there is a
wonderful discussion
about this method in
Atom-Photon interaction.
It's the Exercise
18 on page 601.
So mathematically,
what we assume
is that the population
vary slowly.
For instance, they vary
at the Rabi frequency.
So therefore, we can say that
over the rapid time evolution
of the coherences-- rho
1, 2 plus rho 2, 1--
so this is the rapid time
evolution of the coherences.
But for times which are on
the order of 1 over kappa,
the population are not changing.
The population change over
the much longer time scale,
which is the period of
the Rabi oscillation.
So therefore, for
the short time scale,
I can sort of pretend that
this term is constant.
And for obvious reasons, let
me now call this constant term,
or slowly varying term, it is,
at least for short time scales,
the equilibrium value.
So the way how we
should read it is
that the coherences
will very, very rapidly
damp to this equilibrium value.
And this equilibrium
value was given
by the population,
which may slowly change.
But that means, now, by
eliminating coherences,
we obtain a rate equation
for the populations only.
So therefore, if you
neglect short transients
over the short
time 1 over kappa,
the coherences are
always given by
this quasi-equilibrium
value, which
is expressed by the population.
And therefore, we can go to
our master equation, which
was a master equation
for the of diagram matrix
elements of the density
matrix, and we can now
replace the coherences
by an expression which
involves only population.
So we get now closed equations
for only the population.
I'm sort of emphasizing that
because you may have asked
yourself, when you have the
rate equation a la Einstein,
with the a and b
coefficient, these are just
rate equation for populations.
But here, in our class, we've
always talked about the density
matrix, how important
the coherences are.
The coherences are important.
Without coherences, you would
never absorb or emit light.
But if the coherences can
be expressed by populations,
you don't need a differential
equation for them.
OK.
So with that now, we
have our master equation
for the population.
And by just inserting
that, we find this.
And we were interested
in the decay of rho 1, 1.
Or this is also the population
of the atom in the excited
state.
If we initially start
where rho 1, 1 is large,
we're interested in
the initial decay,
then the population in
the ground state is small.
And we find, indeed, that
there is exponential decay
of the initial distribution.
And the decay rate,
gamma z, gamma cavity,
is given by this expression.
So therefore, what we
find is-- but you know it
by now-- the effect that the
stronger we damp the cavity,
the smaller, the weaker, is
the decay of the initial state.
And I've already
explained to you
that one picture to explain
that is that we have the excited
state, we have the ground state.
The ground state
gets damped by kappa.
And therefore, the
time evolution,
which is given by the vacuum
Rabi oscillation, slows down.
OK.
Yes.
Any questions?
So we have now resolved
for gamma cavity.
We have a result
how the atom decays
in the presence of the cavity.
And I want to rewrite this
for you in a very nice way.
Namely, I want to show
you the famous result
that, when an atom
emits in a cavity,
that the atom can decay faster
than the spontaneous decay.
Because if the cavity
has a resonance,
the cavity changes the
vacuum around the atom.
It increases the
density of modes.
And therefore, there
is a stimulation
of the atom into the cavity.
So I don't have to
do any other math
than just rewriting our result
of gamma cavity in other units,
in other ways.
And then we can compare it to
the natural decay of an atom
without the cavity.
So what we want to
do now is we want
to take the cavity-induced
decay of the excited state,
and we want to compare with
the natural decay rate, gamma.
So I just have to rewrite
things in a few units.
The cavity-induced decay is
the vacuum Rabi oscillation
squared over kappa.
So let me remind you that
the Rabi frequency is always
given by an dipole moment
times electric field.
It's a matrix element.
Well, there's one of
those factors of 2.
And H bar keeps
the units correct.
And in the case of the
vacuum Rabi oscillation,
the electric field is the
electric field, so to speak,
of one photon in
the cavity volume.
And there is a factor
of 2, so this is now
the volume of the cavity.
So therefore, the
vacuum Rabi frequency
is a dipole moment
times 2 atomic resonance
frequency epsilon 0 h bar v.
And that means now-- and
this is a nice result--
that the cavity-induced decay
is omega 0 square over kappa.
And I just use the above
result for omega 0.
And for kappa, I
introduce the Q factor
of the cavity, which is
the number of oscillations
before it is damped.
It's omega over kappa.
And with that, I can rewrite
the cavity-induced decay
as 2d squared epsilon
null H bar v times Q.
And if you remember, from
part 1 of the course,
or standard textbook result,
that spontaneous decay is
a dipole moment squared times
frequency to the power 3,
then we obtain
the famous result,
which is called the
Purcell factor, namely
that the decay in
the cavity, compared
to the decay in free space,
is proportional to the Q
of the cavity.
There is a numerical prefector.
But then, what enters
is the wavelength
of the photon cubed
over the volume.
So the case of eta
larger than 1--
and it's actually interesting
that this result is completely
independent of
atomic properties.
So in other words, every
atom you put in a cavity,
no matter what its
dipole moment is,
it will decay with a rate
which is Q times larger.
There are many ways
how to look at it.
You can say, if the cavity
consists of two mirrors,
you create Q mirror
images of your atom.
And you have sort
of an atom which
has a Q times stronger
dipole moment.
And therefore, because the
mirror images also radiate,
and therefore you get
a Q times faster decay.
So this limit makes sense in
many, many different pictures.
And it's a general result
that, if an atom emits
in a cavity with finesse
Q, you get a Q times
enhancement of
spontaneous decay.
So this is called
cavity-enhanced spontaneous
emission.
It goes back to Purcell in 1946.
And you can see the
whole field of cavity QED
depends on this effect, that you
can enhance spontaneous decay.
Or it's the opposite.
If an atom has a
resonance frequency
between two modes of the
cavity, the spontaneous decay
is inhibited.
And this is sort of what
is exploited in cavity QED.
Let me just conclude
here by saying
that our assumptions
have to be consistent.
In our derivation,
we neglected gamma.
When I said the two
Lindblad operators,
we only look at the
leakage out of the photon.
We neglect spontaneous decay.
So of course, this requires
that eta is larger 1.
So this is the consistent range
of validity of our result.
Secondly, we discussed
the limit of overdamping,
which requires that kappa has to
be larger than the vacuum Rabi
frequency.
And therefore, the above
result is valued for large Q.
Q has to be sufficiently large,
but cannot be larger than this
value.
Any questions?
Nancy?
AUDIENCE: For kappa, is that
the loss in the cavity--
is there any difference
between the loss and the cavity
because it's a cavity?
Or the loss is into other
modes of the cavity?
PROFESSOR: Kappa is the loss.
You can say kappa is the rate
at which a photon in the cavity
is lost.
AUDIENCE: Is lost from
the cavity totally?
Or is lost into another
mode inside the cavity?
Is there any difference?
Is v here just one
mode inside the cavity.
PROFESSOR: Well, we
have not an element--
OK, if the mirror
has imperfections,
we usually think of light
leaking out of the mirror.
If the mirror is absorbing
because the coating has
a tiny little bit
of absorption, you
know, from the beam
splitter analogy,
that a small absorption
is equivalent here
to a small transmission factor.
Usually, we don't consider
that the light transforms
from one mode of the
cavity to the other.
It's either absorbed
or leaking out.
But if you assume that the
mirrors are not super polished
and they scatter
light a little bit,
then you would have a mechanism
that the light in the cavity
scatters into other modes.
And all those losses
are summarized
in one coupling constant, kappa.
Let me finish the class
today and this week
by showing to you the recent
nature paper by the Innsbrook
group.
We've talked so much
about Lindblad operators.
And the Lindblad
operators, the dissipation,
tells us what is the
effect of the environment.
And usually, you would say,
well, if you have an atom,
and it interacts
with the environment,
what is the equilibrium state?
Well, if you just
have the vacuum,
the atom goes to
the ground state.
And the ground state
is the attractor,
the stable state of the system.
If you drive the system
with one laser beam,
the attractor state where
the system goes into
is the steady state solution
of the optical Bloch equation.
That all sounds a
little bit boring.
But in this paper, based on
this theoretical suggestion
of Peter Zola and an
experimental realization
with trapped ions at
Innsbrook, they actually
engineered an environment,
engineered Lindblad operators
in such a way that
the system of two ions
was relaxing into a Bell state.
So you engineer
now the environment
that therm-- I wanted to say
thermal equilibrium, no--
the equilibrium state with the
environment, the dissipation,
leads to a Bell state.
Well, it's a little bit
complicated how it is done,
but I just want to just look at
a few highlighted key messages.
So the idea is, here,
engineering of dissipation,
creating experimentally
dissipative operators.
We usually manipulate quantum
system with Hamilton operators.
But here, it is manipulated
not by the H operator,
but by the L operator.
And so the idea here is to have
an evolution of the density
matrix, a linear mapping that
the density matrix evolves
in a certain way.
I think you'll
recognize partial trace.
You'll recognize
a few equations,
a few results which
we have discussed.
And what you see here is
exactly the Lindblad form.
And what they did is, by
using a number of laser
beams in quantum operation,
they designed operators, z,
jump operators, Lindblad
operators, in such a way
that the system was damping
out into a Bell state.
So that seems a new
frontier for research.
It goes by the title that we
can do quantum simulations,
using trapped ions and
cold atoms of Hamiltonians.
But we can also quantum simulate
very special environments.
Maybe environments
which it would
be hard to find them
in nature, but they
are quantum-mechanically
allowed possible environments.
And they may have
new features which
have not been explored so far.
I will add this
paper to the website,
if you want to
read more about it.
Any question?
Then a reminder.
No class next week.
Monday is Patriot's Day.
I'm out of town on
Wednesday, but you
have a homework to solve.
I rather feel you should
continue to have a homework
assignment every
week, because then you
have more time at the end of
the term for the term paper.
I always have 10
homework assignments.
So when we spread
them out more, there
is less time left at the end
of the semester for the term
paper.
So I decided, since we have
covered enough material,
we have a wonderful homework
assignment for next week.